the country's chicken reserves are
running dangerously low
now this is a crisis for kfc
connoisseurs but
big business sees this as an opportunity
to undermine workers
companies across other industries have
also noted the difficulty of recruiting
new workers
with some business owners attributing
the problem to increased unemployment
benefits
that make it more attractive to remain
on government assistance
in other words they don't want to raise
wages and instead hope for more
cheap foreign labor as americans can
collect unemployment biden of course
will oblige and the americans will stay
out of work with just these juiced up
welfare benefits here now stephen miller
former senior adviser to president trump
founder of america first legal stephen
um
your analysis of this situation people
are thinking of chick-fil-a and
they're not going to be able to get
their sandwiches but there are serious
underlying issues here well i had the
privilege of working
on the executive order that president
trump issued
several months earlier that banned the
entry of foreign workers
during the pandemic that executive order
was based on a department of labor
analysis
which found that a historic number of
american workers
were sidelined and out of work because
of the pandemic and pandemic related
closures
the largest labor surplus anyone's ever
seen
joe biden came into office he terminated
that executive order it got very little
attention
allowing for the unrestricted entry of
foreign workers
whose sole reason sole reason for
entering the country is to fill
u.s jobs these companies are
simply addicted to cheap labor it's just
that simple lore but
we've been talking about this for years
yeah this is what they say every time i
bring this up
they'll say americans won't do these
jobs
laura chicken working at chicken
factories processing centers
it's work no american wants to do that's
they're always their answer
it's so it's so eminently disprovable i
mean if you go into a state or community
that has lower levels of immigration
you'll see jobs
being done by u.s workers you know you
can go into states for example you can
go to a fast food restaurant
they'll be high schoolers working at a
fast food restaurant
now i don't begrudge anybody who's here
as an immigrant who's working
i begrudge u.s policy that brings in
such a large
number of workers that it displaces u.s
workers
and recently arrived immigrants i mean
again you can go
into states that have lower rates of
immigration and you'll see
high schoolers doing jobs you'll see
people
in in summer doing jobs you know working
on golf courses whatever it may be
but in other states they say oh no only
immigrants can do these jobs it's a
slander
against american workers laura well big
business is already putting the pressure
though
uh stephen on on biden's economic team
the washington post reporting that
senior biden economic officials have in
recent weeks been peppered by complaints
from restaurant groups in the
construction industry other businesses
about their inability
to find enough workers stephen what
about
a glut of workers that's what they
always want they never want a tight
labor market
why joe biden is the phoniest
fakest populist in the history of
mankind he is doing the bidding of
corporate america
he's issued one executive action after
another to make it easier
for cheap guest workers people on visas
to come into the country
at a fraction of the pay being afforded
to american workers
and he's doing it for lobbyists and big
corporations who just want to make extra
money at the
expense of american workers these
government policies distort markets
they push u.s workers out of industries
they push u.s workers
out of entire lines of work and then
those same companies come back and they
say it's still not enough
we need even more immigration we need
even more foreign workers
it hurts immigrants it hurts u.s workers
it
only helps joe biden's donors and i hope
the gop won't just talk about the
southern border
but they'll also talk about the
importation of cheap
visa workers they'll talk about interior
enforcement they'll talk about refugee
policy
the whole panoply of item policies that
are undermining
the u.s workforce in extremely
corporatist
anti-progressive ways i'm sure liz
cheney will get right on that stephen
thank you so much thank you